so
some things i'm going to train
i'm going to trade marshally marshally
does not mean i go fast
i try to outrace you that wouldn't be i
don't try to outmastery that's actually
not marshall okay but a train with
presence and with no openings and with
the art yin yang reconciliations do you
see and that also means that i train
from the second mind aspect okay so i'm
not i'm not wigging out
over your pain
or your owies or what i'm doing to you
do you understand it doesn't it doesn't
make me cry
that's your problem
do you understand
you need to figure out how to absorb and
accept
on this side and i don't i'm not
interested in your
psychology or your mood swings or
anything like that do you get it i have
no nothing of that the second mind
aspect does not have those things i'm
just feeling humanly
so
does it change with my uk my mind does
not change
so he's going to get hurt i can tell as
he disconnects
right there his elbow's taking a lot of
pressure
you need to figure it out
that's not it not letting go does not do
it so i take these openings
body
[Music]
not your arm right here is arm but it's
not strong enough so it gets tweaked
here can you feel that
your body moves
hold your center no
up
then when it moves your whole center
moves
just
whole body
there you go
[Music]
get it out of your elbow your job is to
get out of your elbow
go so you push
push
you can stand up and push stand up
okay
do you does that feel tight to you yes
so
it's not this
you're coming into me
push
okay
that's what you're doing are you coming
to me boom
that's what i'm doing
so i'm not going
here you pushing boom grab
okay you see that then same thing here
there's your resistance
i'm not trying to shove it down
this goes into
the ground point the ground point
[Music]
oh you got twisted that got really tight
didn't it
you gotta do what he learned
what did it do it's gonna get tight
again you see how tight it got
we're gonna fix that first
lock your body lock your body
and your whole body will move
you let it happen
better you see didn't go in
there you do it again lock your body
not his skin right got tighter
oh it's gonna get tight again
i'm moving on this part
absorb
[Music]
even into slow
still worse
silver is high does it matter
it's all going in your elbow
call you projection
not
external
you have to be stronger
okay
go